[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone salcon here from finding
novel cures for a seemingly incurable
disease to diagnosing what's going on
with someone if you're a physician or a
nurse you can imagine there's incredible
creativity in biology
and don't take my word for it you're now
going to meet some of my friends who can
tell you more about that connection
between biology and creativity
[Applause]
[Music]
all science careers involve creativity
think about it we're asking and
answering questions and we're solving
the world's problems so the more
creatively we can solve the world's
problems the more new ideas and concepts
and approaches we can use to address the
world's problems the better off we'll be
creativity is the guiding force on the
path to good science so there isn't a
science job out there that doesn't
benefit from creativity like you could
be an engineer building more efficient
transistors for tinier and tinier phones
you could be a climate scientist
figuring out how we can reduce our
carbon footprint and save the world from
climate catastrophe or an agricultural
researcher deducing efficient ways to
feed the planet or maybe an entomologist
like me uh understanding how
relationships between organisms keep us
all healthy creativity is important in
all of these careers one really cool job
is uh
is working for a science museum and so
the people who are like the the chief
directors or bioscientists or what have
you for science museums usually have a
biology or a science background of some
kind maybe have gone through even being
a phd or a postdoctoral fellow
and
their job is to design exhibits for
for visitors to museums and
come up with engaging ways to share
ideas in science and so i just think
that's a really cool job
that you might not immediately think of
as we move forward as scientists as
biologists
um the old adage is true
a picture is worth a thousand
words so what is that image that graph
that graphic or even that imagery
um that that really gets to the core of
your idea
it almost gets to advertising you want
that image to stick in your listeners
minds
that both
lets them understand
the undeniably complex concept that
you're trying to convey but also makes
it memorable
and developing that skill to come up
with that picture that is truly worth a
thousand words is going to be
the skill that we will all need
going into the future creativity plays a
role in my life
pretty much every single day by
reminding me not to stop just because
i've reached a setback like
hitting a wall as you're moving towards
a goal doesn't have to be the end for
that goal
to me it just means that the path to
success isn't going to be quite as
straightforward as i originally thought
like
the way around that wall may require me
to climb over it or tunnel under it or
or maybe even dig straight through it
but if i'm creative enough i can
probably find a way to get to the other
side and this plays out for me in the
lab literally every single day it feels
a tenacity that can see you through
things like graduate school if you ever
choose to go that route
[Music]
i allow my brain to do the work to get
into my creative zone when i have a
problem to resolve sometimes i just
sleep on it and i let my subconscious
mind
work through resolving problems and
solving problems our brains are always
at work like trying to
be
fragmented break apart the things that
we encounter
so
i spend a little time thinking about how
i can approach things creatively
and then i spend a little time not
thinking about those things and allowing
my brain and my subconscious mind to
have an opportunity to do the work for
me a lot of times when i come back
afterwards i've got a great idea i've
got the answers and i have new ways to
solve and resolve things that i've been
thinking about to get into my creative
zone i do something that i'd like to
call productive procrastination
i start what i'm working on way before
it's due and then in fits and starts i i
work
well giving my mind permission to wander
to things that absolutely are not on the
agenda
it's encouraged
some of my most creative experiences
some of my best songwriting educational
videos and even scientific breakthroughs
while i was supposed to be working on
something totally unrelated and this
won't work for everyone but my mind is
most creative when it's free to go on
unplanned adventures
good music also helps a great playlist
to me is worth its weight in gold my
playlists are special because they only
include instrumental music
and songs in languages that i don't
actually speak so my thoughts don't get
too pulled into the lyrics themselves
[Music]
i've used creative communication to
solve problems related to especially
people learning different science for
example in chemistry people sometimes
have a hard time understanding
subatomic particles and molecules and
atoms and making those connections
between quantities and numbers so
instead of jumping right into that which
can be very difficult for people i've
learned to be creative and use analogies
or relating that to something that is
more accessible such as cooking or money
or building something and then when
people can make the relation between
something large and familiar to
something small or subatomic and
unfamiliar it makes it easier for them
to make those connections and build upon
that knowledge so several years ago i
started making videos of myself
explaining biology and entomology in
language that was accessible and
familiar to people my age and people who
don't fit the stereotypical model of a
scientist
it's a choice that i'm really glad that
i made actually i've received so much
positive feedback about videos no more
complicated than me holding a bug in
front of a camera and
actually
just like this
me
literally
holding a bug in front of a camera and
explaining what makes it tick
note to self
i should make a video about what makes
ticks tick that'd be pretty cool wait
sorry there's nothing here nor there um
the
point of what i'm saying is the choice
not to excise my personality the choice
to bring all of my quirkiness into how i
communicate is what seems to make the
difference a big part of being creative
really can be just figuring out how to
bring all of you to whatever it is that
you choose to do
[Music]
i think biology is so critical for
everybody to learn because it defines
who we are
as human beings as animals it defines
the whole animal kingdom and then it
goes on to define the whole plant
kingdom
the insect kingdom
understanding those
principles of how
living things
are organized
is not only a beautiful thing to
understand but it gives deep insight and
deep appreciation
for our own lives and i think that is
the core of why i find it so
important that everybody study this this
beautiful
area of of academia biology is super
important to learn for so many reasons
but the reason that stands out most to
me is well
the rarity of life outside of our little
corner of the universe
you might not know what i mean but stick
with me for a sec so so we are
positively surrounded by biology every
day here on earth but we haven't
encountered life or even evidence of
life outside of this little blue marvel
even though there is so much cosmic real
estate out there
life is really complicated and that goes
for starting and sustaining life
somehow ancient organisms made it work
here but that doesn't mean that it's
easy all of us carry on this legacy of
life finding a way but one day maybe
life will have to find a way through us
maybe earth becomes inhospitable for
some reason and we have to figure out
how to live somewhere else on that day
success will depend on how well we
understand the heaps of obstacles that
the stubbornness of life has already
overcome